for me the first expectation for the
European Council is firstly to
recognize the priority given to
defense secondly, as we know that
this priority is difficult in this
period of budgetary austerity
to commit to the methods for
making this effort  most
effective defense system and that means
cooperation that means
playing on all the synergies that
the policies of
the European Union can bring and that means
agreeing on priorities so what
we have proposed is  is also
to illustrate this message from the
European Council and on the subject we hope that
they will come back regularly to
verify the reality of the implementation
of the commitments
of the illustrated by four programs so
there on the streets mochis straw the
system teaser this  which translates with a
few approximations in French by drones
secondly on space
communication satellites cyber protection
cyber defense and supplies  in
flight therefore key capabilities for
the future on which we are proposing
concrete commitments which
once again cover the various synergies that
can be created in the European union
the question of the decrease
in defense budgets is
obviously a crucial question
in  done in three years our member states
have reduced their defense spending by
10 billion euros and
this leads to a reduction in fact of 25
% of the defense effort so we are
indeed very far from the effort to
which the member states  have
undertaken to consent to the without which we
can help them is to return this
expense whatever it is but
knowing full well that we cannot do more
with less more with less it does
not work
but to return  this effective expenditure and
this efficiency notably involves
cooperation, thereby
concentrating on the priorities which
prepare the future and in particular the
technologies which ensure our know
domi and our  re independence and to
seek all possible synergies
I think that for the defense industry
the European Council via a moment of
almost absolute urgency the
European defense industry remains
a high-performance and
high-performance industry technologically
but if it is not  there is
no commitment on the defense effort
there is no commitment on
programs with timetables with
very clear perspectives our
defense industry whether it is
big industrialists or whether it is  actions of
smes really risk a situation where
it could decline with a point to
including with a point of no return so
it is a really key moment for
the defense industry where there is need
once again that the and that the  heads
of state and government at their level
define a priority for defense
define their commitments on
programs and also define
incentives that will allow investment
and yet another  time to find all the
possible synergies
in terms of programs in terms
of investment therefore which allow
our industry to survive
when we have budget cuts
when we cut the budget
there the first item that our ministries
of defense are obliged to reduce
c  is the boss of research and
technology in many cases
is therefore there we are really
taking a considerable risk
for the future that is why at the
European Defense Agency we have on the one hand
defined  the most
critical technologies for our
strategic autonomy for our freedom of action
and to prepare for the future so we have a
list by mutual agreement between member states of the
essential priorities the commission
itself has done this work in a
much more general way on the  all
of the civil
and dual technologies
the european space agency has done the
same thing in the space field so
we know which are the
critical technologies on which we  must focus
our collective effort and our
investment is therefore also one of the
expectations of the European Council and for this
the work that has been done at the
European Defense Agency prepares the ground
is to
focus resources and efforts on
its technologies  research and
development needed for
the future